only yesterday is a brand-new studio
ghibli film coming out this weekend for
the very first time in the United States
except it's not actually brand new this
film originally came out in 1991 in
Japan it was directed by Esau Takahata
who's made films like grave of the
fireflies and the tale of the princess
kaguya and finally over two decades
later it is officially getting a release
in America thanks to G kids now why did
it take so long well that's because
Disney was a little bit afraid back when
movies like My Neighbor Totoro was a big
favorite amongst kids my age on
clamshell VHS this film was nowhere to
be seen and that is because of some
aspects of its plot a 27 year old woman
is travelling to the countryside to
relax she really wants to select go
she's going there to work in the fields
she really wants to work with her hands
outside and she wants to feel as if she
is adding something to herself into her
life and along her train ride she
reminisces about her past as a young
girl all of her experiences in school a
lot of her firsts her first crush her
first time trying pineapple her first
period and that's where Disney got
scared there's a long sequence in this
movie dedicated to her discovering her
womanhood and for whatever reason Disney
decided that's not good for the kids to
see we're not going to release this film
in America and it's taken this long to
get to the shores of America and I am so
glad and I finally got to watch this
movie because I'm not a big fan of
watching films unofficially like a fan
sub or something I like the idea of
sitting down and watching it officially
like I'm in a theatre right now watching
only yesterday and that is such a great
feeling I got to see this movie early
and all those Studio Ghibli seems to
have their brakes on at the moment it
was so nice to see another Studio Ghibli
film even if it is over 20 years old
because this film is truly remarkable
and for a lot of reasons one of the
biggest ones is its innocence this film
is so blissfully happy it's a movie that
you can watch and actually feel
invigorated with warm feelings how often
does that happen anymore
every movie has to be dark and gritty it
is so nice to sit down and watch a movie
that was pleasant when's the last time
you watched a movie that was pleasant
does that even
happen anymore but it's not just the
vibe in the tone of the movie the
animation really impressed me and I'm
not just talking about it looks great
because it's studio ghibli of course the
animation is going to look very good
what I loved about it are certain
touches that Esau taka how to made for
instance our character in the present
day this 27 year old woman all of the
animation for these sequences looks
crisp and clear and vibrant
it looks very now it looks very
realistic whenever she's reminiscing
about her childhood however everything
has a haze around it it looks a little
unclear slightly blurry the backgrounds
aren't in focus there isn't a lot of
detail given to these backgrounds okay
so what you know who cares what the
animation is different big deal that's
kind of what I thought for like five or
six minutes until I realized that what
they're doing with the animation is
almost reflect when our own human minds
do when we recall our past think about a
memory from when you were like five or
six years old if you're 27
remembering that far back things get
hazy details aren't clear
you just remember certain moments you
remember things that you specifically
saw right in front of you and maybe
something that affected you deeply but
the rest is kind of a haze
it's brilliant it's a masterstroke I
think I think it's a genius way of
telling this story and it went over my
head for a while it's the kind of thing
that you don't really pay attention to
it do you really start thinking about it
and it's just so awesome that a movie
like this even though some people might
refer to it as a cartoon is that deep
throughout almost the entire film my
heartstrings were sufficiently tugged
this is a gorgeous beautiful movie and I
truly truly hope more people get to see
it finally now that it's coming over to
America my one issue with the movie is
so small it's just basically going back
and forth sometimes between these two
time periods youth to adulthood it's not
always very cohesive sometimes you feel
as if you're in one story a little bit
too long you want to go back to the
other one and sometimes you're in the
story not long enough and you want more
it's just that it's really the smallest
little thing it's like a nitpick really
I'm going to give only yesterday and a -
Thank You G kids for finally getting the
rights to this movie I've wanted to see
in my entire life and I officially got
to watch it and it was just so great
thank you so much for releasing this
movie in the United States and I hope
you guys get a chance to see it and it's
coming to a theater near you because I
highly highly highly highly
and I hope you stay tuned for this
Sunday it's going to be a hilarious 'ti
Sunday and that is going to be for
Supergirl not the new TV show the 1984
movie I just I watched it
yeah so I'm going to talk about that if
that's if that's cool with you guys cuz
Sunday Sunday I'll see you Sunday guys
thank you as always for watching thank
you very very much and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes